décidé d'être mobile pour mentir
à la maison n'attendez pas quelque chose pour faire vos courses aussi
fils travaille tous les travaux sur comment ou
mentir jusqu'à ce que quelque chose vous soit bien apporté
encore une fois, plus de travail que de rester assis à la maison
gagner une indemnité à vie
continue
[la musique]
depuis que je suis un peu grutier électrique bien
les pensées étaient telles mais se sont fixées sur quelqu'un
si vous faites un type de kéfir, eh bien, j'ai trouvé un site
à savoir téléphériques
la puissance est différente il y a différentes options
s'est arrêté brusquement puis a commencé
déjà de lui ce filtre a commencé sauvagement
réfléchir à la façon
concevoir de sorte qu'il soit
[la musique]
est sorti s'est enfui du balcon d'une manière ou d'une autre mais
puis des réflexions sur la façon de tout faire
la navette n'est pas quelqu'un abaissé avec et vous
bouton sur cette entreprise
[la musique]